härtere strafen für täter mehr druck auf
facebook und co die bundesregierung
beschließt neue regeln gegen hass und
hetze im internet kälte hunger und keine
ahnung wie es weitergehen soll
hunderttausende syrer viele kinder
fliehen vor den bomben des regimes in
damaskus
erling hollern schock paris der
dortmunder neuzugang trifft im champions
league-achtelfinale doppelt und genießt
den besten abend seiner karriere
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und habt in all der
sport nachher mit kristin otto und
dieser nachrichten mittwoch steht
zunächst im zeichen von gigantischen
umwälzungen und herausforderungen vor
die die digitale welt uns alle stellt
europa will eine groß angelegte digitale
aufholjagd starten dazu gleich mehr
in deutschland heute ein schritt der die
bürger und letztlich die gesellschaft
schützen soll vor besonders bösartigen
hass im netz ein neues gesetz soll mehr
schutz für die user bringen höhere
strafen für die täter mehr pflichten für
facebook und co
denn die müssen in besonders schweren
fällen die entsprechenden post künftig
von sich aus beim bundeskriminalamt
melden also gewaltvideos nazipropaganda
vergewaltigungs und morddrohungen worte
im netz aus den taten werden können
dominik tepco berichtet rechtsextremer
anschlag auf eine synagoge in halle die
ermordung des kasseler
regierungspräsidenten weiter lücke im
vergangenen jahr gerade in den sozialen
netzwerken werden die taten verherrlicht
dagegen will die bundesregierung jetzt
vorgehen solche taten entstehen nicht
aus dem nichts sondern sie entwickeln
sich und deswegen ist es wichtig an den
ursprung zu gehen und das sind oftmals
hassbotschaften die im netz weiter
transportiert noch gesteigert werden
künftig müssen plattformen wie facebook
oder tik tok schwerwiegende hass
kommentare von sich aus melden an eine
zentrale stelle beim bundeskriminalamt
300 neue mitarbeiter geben die meldungen
von hier weiter an die
staatsanwaltschaften dort aber droht
überlastung fürchten kritiker
neue gesetze helfen wenig wenn sie von
der justiz nicht umgesetzt werden können
und zwar zügig umgesetzt werden können
und deswegen brauchen wir mehr stellen
bei der staatsanwaltschaft mehr
richterinnen und richter die diese
verfahren dann auch zügig betreiben ihr
neues gesetz hat die bundesregierung in
einem punkt entschärft ursprünglich
sollten die behörden auch passwörter von
nutzern ab fragen dürfen
das dürfen sie künftig aber nur bei
schweren straftaten und wenn ein richter
das erlaubt dennoch wird es kein
vertrauen dem user oder dem nutzer im
internet geben dass er weiß dass
potenziell seine passwort weiterhin
herausgegeben werden dürfen
die erste hürde hat das gesetz mit dem
kabinettsbeschluss heute genommen als
nächstes muss der bundestag noch
zustimmen
und jetzt europas digitale zukunft da
soll sich enorm viel tun sagt die
eu-kommission
denn die situation aktuell sieht maus
für europa die giganten die so vieles in
diesem bereich bestimmen also google
amazon und facebook allesamt aus den usa
ein ebenbürtiges unternehmen aus europa
fehlanzeige im rennen um
zukunftstechnologien ist die eu
abgehängt und das will sie jetzt ändern
die neue digital strategie soll auch
eine kampfansage sein grüner krüger
erklärt wie die aussieht freie uni
brüssel
kommissionspräsidentin trifft künstliche
intelligenz kurz ki der blick durch die
brille erweitert um eine
computertomografie das bild gehörte
einem echten patienten brauchen klarheit
bei der verwendung solcher daten uns ist
das der flaschen die eu-kommission will
abhelfen will aufholen den wettlauf mit
us internetriesen die ihnen gaben
millionen europäer private daten die
nächste runde aber soll in europa
gegenüber turniers beginnt der kampf um
die industriellen daten und europa wird
der ort weil dieser schlacht dessen
industrie sitzer vor einem datenschatz
soll nun teilen auf einer mega cloud
made in europe mehr daten für bessere
künstliche intelligenz doch schlaue
maschinen entscheiden immer öfter auch
menschen da geht es mal um kleinigkeiten
mal um leben und tod wir wollen also
verstehen was jeweils auf dem spiel
steht bei wenig risiko sollen wenig
regeln gelten mehr risiko heiße mehr
rechte für verbraucher daten ein blick
etwa wenn eine bank pekao über einen
kredit entscheidet so viele regelung
cypher da tauchen selbst die großen in
brüssel auf montag war facebook chef
zuckerberg da offiziell ein zufall des
terminkalenders
es sind nicht hier die sich den
plattformen anpassen müssen es sind die
plattformen die sich europa anpassen
müsste nicht nur der tür
klingt wie eine kampfansage künstliche
intelligenz ist alles andere als
spielerei
wir bleiben noch moment in der politik
ein vorhaben das noch keine
bundesregierung umsetzen konnte und das
jetzt aber kommen wird die grundrente
die regierung hat den gesetzentwurf
heute beschlossen
für diejenigen die jahrzehntelang
gearbeitet aber wenig verdient haben und
deswegen wenig eingezahlt haben in die
rentenkasse ist die grundrente praktisch
ein aufschlag auf die normale rente von
hier profitieren sollen 1,3 millionen
menschen 70 prozent davon frauen
finanziert werden soll sie aus
steuereinnahmen die kosten rund 1,4
milliarden euro allein für das kommende
jahr ausbauen sagt jetzt mit den details
petra vogel 62 jahre alt hat ihr leben
lang hart gearbeitet verdient als
reinigungskraft im krankenhaus 11 eur 44
die stunde der blick auf ihren letzten
rentenbescheid macht petra vogel angst
vor dem ruhestand
der betrag den man jetzt und ich heraus
bekommt wo man wie ich 38 jahre
gearbeitet in vollzeit 761 euro
menschen die wie petra vogel für wenig
lohn lange gearbeitet haben bekommen
nach 33 jahren einen zuschlag auf die
rente der nach 35 jahren die volle höhe
erreicht das können bis zu 405 euro sein
das ist ein großer sozialpolitischer
meilenstein die größte sozialreform
wahrscheinlich dieser legislaturperiode
es ist ein erfolg aber vor allem für die
menschen die jeden tag hart arbeiten die
den laden unser land am laufen halten
eine lange zwischen union und spd
umstrittene bedürftigkeitsprüfung wird
es nicht geben dafür eine
einkommensprüfung für alleinstehende
gilt ein freibetrag von 1250 euro
monatlich für paare von 1950 euro
ein schritt in die richtige richtung
aber längst nicht genug urteilt die
linkspartei
um alle menschen garantiert vor
altersarmut zu schützen brauchen wir
erst ein höheres rentenniveau und
zweitens brauchen wir eine solidarische
mindestrente die sicherstellt dass kein
rentner keine rentnerin unter die
armutsgrenze fällt rund 1,3 millionen
menschen sollen von der grundrente
profitieren
petra vogel dürfte eine von ihnen seien
in thüringen ist ein ende der
regierungskrise nach wie vor nicht
absehbar
eine übergangsregierung unter christine
lieberknecht von der cdu ist vom tisch
sie steht für die längerfristige
variante die ihre eigene partei
vorgeschlagen hat nicht zur verfügung
thüringens cdu chef mike mohring ist
jetzt noch mehr unter druck und fordert
für seine landespartei mehr spielraum
andreas weise berichtet aus erfurt kein
guter morgen für mike mohring er hat
gerade erfahren dass ex cdu
ministerpräsidentin lieberknecht nicht
mehr als übergangsregierungschef hin zur
verfügung steht ich bin aus der debatte
raus sagt sie in einem zeitungsinterview
wer jetzt keine neuwahlen will muss bodo
ramelow mit verlässlicher mehrheit
zurück ins ministerpräsidentenamt
verhelfen
eine kaum verbrämte aufforderung an die
thüringer cdu das kooperationsverbot der
bundespartei irgendwie zu unterlaufen
eingekeilt zwischen linkem und af.de
sucht die thüringer union nach auswegen
eingemauert in beschlusslagen lässt sich
schwer lösung finden und deswegen
braucht dieser prozess der so schwierig
für thüringen es auch eine debatte die
wir noch mal neu bei der vermessung der
cdu in dieser frage führen müssen
mohring selbst bleibt vorerst an der
fraktionsspitze eine für heute
angesetzte vertrauensabstimmung wurde
abgesagt am zweiten märz wie die cdu
fraktion einen neuen vorstand wählen
mohring tritt dann nicht mehr an
für die linke gibt es nach dem rückzug
lieberknechts noch zwei möglichkeiten
das eine ist eine rot rot grüne
minderheitsregierung mit programm nun zu
stützen
die variante die uns lieber ist ist
natürlich schnelle neuwahlen und endlich
wieder stabile mehrheiten in thüringen
zu schaffen
seit dem nachmittag laufen die gespräche
zwischen rot-rot-grün und der cdu wieder
bis freitag will man eine lösung finden
und die bundes cdu sucht weiter nach
einer neuen führungsspitze gestern traf
sich die noch vorsitzende annegret kramp
karrenbauer mit friedrich merz einem
möglichen kandidaten für ihre nachfolge
heute dann mit armin laschet und jens
spahn
zuvor hatte auch bewerber norbert
röttgen seinen termin bei ihr wie es
jetzt bei der union weiter gehen soll
dazu csu chef markus söder in der zdf
sendung was nun
jetzt melden sich ja fast täglich neue
kandidaten muss sehr aufpassen dass zum
beispiel durch vielleicht falsche
zeitabläufe oder zu langer zeit abläufe
will nicht eine situation in der spd
plötzlich bekommen mit kandidaten und
abstimmungsverfahren die nicht nur eine
partei so nach deutschland leben
das ganze interview mit dem
csu-vorsitzenden können sie gleich nach
und sehen in was nun herr söder 1920
hier im zdf die etwa 34.000 mitarbeiter
der supermarktkette real bangen um ihre
jobs denn der handelskonzern metro hat
real an einen finanzinvestor verkauft
von den aktuell rund 270 märkten sollen
zunächst etwa 50 erhalten bleiben
die anderen filialen sollen größtenteils
einen mitbewerber wie rewe oder edeka
verkauft werden rund 30 droht die
schließung
welche filialen das genau sind steht
aber noch nicht fest
die kartellbehörden müssen dem
weiterverkauf noch zustimmen
acht jahre gefängnisstrafe gab es heute
für den betreuer einer pfadfindergruppe
wegen kindesmissbrauchs die richter
ordneten an dass nach ende der haft
geprüft wird ob der ehemalige betreuer
überhaupt wieder freikommen kann der
mann 42 jahre alt war leiter einer
evangelischen pfadfinder gruppe in
staufen im breisgau und hat sich nach
überzeugung des gerichts über jahre an
vier jungen vergangen
in insgesamt 124 fällen
die opfer waren zwischen neun und 13
jahre alt der bürgerkrieg in syrien wer
dachte schlimmer kann es nicht mehr
werden muss neu denken das ist die
aktuelle situation hier machthaber
baschar al assad hat mit hilfe von
russland fast das ganze land wieder
unter seine kontrolle gebracht nur der
nordwesten ist noch rebellengebiet doch
us truppen bombardieren dort jetzt
massiv und rücken weiter vor
hunderttausende menschen fliehen können
aber nicht über die grenze in die türkei
denn die es dicht und so drängen sich
immer mehr flüchtlinge auf einem immer
kleineren gebiet in überfüllten lagern
ohne ausreichend essen bei klirrender
kälte uli gack endlos scheinende
vormarsch syrische truppen in italy
es sind solche videos die zur propaganda
der regierung assad passen
man werde nicht ruhen so heißt es bis
rebellen besiegt und das ganze land
wieder unter kontrolle sei
in assad seine truppen nicht aus der
region idleb zurückziehe droht präsident
erdogan in ankara heute sei ein
militäreinsatz eine frage der zeit
säbelrasseln und militärischer aufmarsch
auf türkischer seite
eine militärische eskalation zwischen
der türkei und syrien droht die
humanitäre katastrophe in der provinz
idlib ist längst realität
800.000 menschen so die un sind auf der
flucht vor kämpfen zwischen assad und
zumeist islamistischen rebellen ins
lager der regierung wollen und können
viele nicht die grenze zur türkei ist
geschlossen
es ist ein verzweifeltes umherirren ohne
beispiel
was wir gerade intel beobachten diese
welle der vertreibung das ist die größte
flucht bewegung seit dem beginn des
krieges 2011 keine seite der
konfliktparteien kümmert es anscheinend
dass vertriebene unter katastrophalen
bedingungen ausharren müssen
im winter bei minusgraden wie dieser
tage auch und schnee der albtraum in
syrien ist längst noch nicht zu ende
weitere eskalation droht eine
verheerende lage sie können den
flüchtlingen mit einer spende helfen an
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 und all diese informationen gibt
es auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
in der türkei gab es gestern freude über
den freispruch von neun bürgerrechtlern
und dann ernüchterung
der industrielle und kultur mehr zehn
osman kavala wird kurz nach dem prozess
ende wieder in haft genommen wegen neuer
vorwürfe kavala saß bereits zwei jahre
in untersuchungshaft dann sagte das
gericht es gebe keine beweise dass er
mit protesten im geopark 2013 die
regierung erdogan habe stürzen wollen
jetzt wirft ihm die staatsanwaltschaft
vor sich am putschversuch von 2016
beteiligt zu haben
erleichterung für rund 500 passagiere
der diamond princess weil bei ihnen kein
corona virus nachgewiesen wurde durften
sie nach zwei wochen in quarantäne das
kreuzfahrtschiff in japan verlassen
auf dem schiff breitet sich der erreger
aber weiter aus seit gestern 79 neue
infektionen ein japanischer
gesundheitsexperte macht unterdessen den
behörden schwere vorwürfe
die zustände auf der diamond princess
seien chaotisch die regierung wies die
kritik zurück
und wie es im ursprungsland des corona
virus in china zurzeit aussieht haben
unsere korrespondenten stephanie
schöneborn und ulf röller beobachtet ihr
film in quarantäne chinas kampf gegen
das corona virus läuft um 1 uhr fünf
kommende nachdem ter fernsehen und jetzt
schon in der zdf mediathek
damit sind wir in dieser sendung beim
sportlichen teil christin das weißt du
zwei themen fußball und biathlon der
franzose martin fourcade gewann bei den
weltmeisterschaften in antholz gold über
20 kilometer ernüchterung dagegen bei
den deutschen männern die das podest
klar erneut verfehlten und mit insgesamt
24 schießfehlern erschreckend chancenlos
waren die deutschen biathleten leighton
weiter ohne medaille im einzel über 20km
erwischten alle fünf einen
rabenschwarzen tag benedikt doll kamen
mit vier strafminuten als beste auf rang
zwölf titelverteidiger anteil verschoss
insgesamt sechs mal daneben und fand
sich so abgeschlagen auf rang 50 wieder
muss man natürlich trotzdem mit einem
besseren ergebnis als mit dem vierer
beim letzten schießen weg gehen also an
solchen tagen wenn man da mal einen
hängen lässt ok oder 24 ist natürlich
indiskutabel johannes böhm aus norwegen
verpasste den titel durch einen zweiten
fehler im letzten anschlag weltmeister
wurde mit nur einem schießfehler matera
folk art aus frankreich bronze ging an
den österreicher dominik landertinger
von unaufhaltsam bis naturgewalt reichen
die superlative über dortmunds erling
hollern nach seinen beiden treffern beim
2 1 triumph des bvb gegen paris st im
gestrigen achtelfinal-hinspiel der
fußball-champions-league ein in sich
ruhender junger mensch der nicht viele
worte macht ich genieße jede sekunde
mein leben ist super erling holland
spricht lieber mit den füßen auch gegen
paris wieder treffsicher 11 tore jetzt
bereits für die borussia in sieben
spielen
das 1 0 gelingt holland mitte der
zweiten halbzeit den ausgleich store für
paris server durch lima lässt er
geradezu mysteriös torhungrige norweger
den siegtreffer folgen zwei zu eins für
dortmund an einem begeisternden abend es
war großartig die atmosphäre ist eine
dieser nächte die hängen bleibt glaube
ich für für lange zeit 19 jahre alt erst
und fast schon ein leitwolf der
westfalen
und heute abend dann leipzig bei
tottenham und wenn sie lotto spielen
dann wird sie das hier interessieren
die gewinnzahlen lauten 37 11 22 27 42
und die superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7 neuer regen ist
unterwegs und auch glätte wird zum
problem
gleich mehr beim wetter und besten telli
für 22 uhr kann ich in den kollegen
claus kleber versprechen der reportagen
und hintergründe im heute journal hat
jetzt gleich nach uns was nun herr söder
mit bettina schausten und peter frey vom
gesamten team der heute 19 uhr sendung
danke für das interesse und ihnen allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das nächste tief
was uns erreicht ist das sturmtief
wiltrud und das kommt von westen als
erstes erreicht uns die warmfront jetzt
kommende nacht und die zieht allmählich
im tagesverlauf ostwärts zum abend dann
morgen eine neue kaltfront mit diesem
tief und dann gibt es schauer gewitter
und sturmböen
schauen wir in die kommende nacht und da
ist die warmfront schon zugange und
bringt regen mit der regen im osten
zieht ab dazwischen klart es auf und
dann kann es glatt werden und der erste
regen der hier mit der warmfront an
kommt der kann auch gefrieren bei
temperaturen von minus zwei grad im
vogtland -3 an den alpen und 5 grad im
westen
morgen im tagesverlauf verlagert sich
die warmfront langsam ostwärts dabei
regnet es etwas sturmböen an der nordsee
im süden regnet es eher richtung
bayerischer wald und bis ins erzgebirge
teilweise auch schnee im süden
freundliches teils sonniges wetter mit
temperaturen zwischen vier grad im
bayerischen wald und 13 grad am
oberrhein
die kommenden tage am interessantesten
ist der samstag hier mit wind und regen
und bis zu 14 grad es geht aber noch
wärmer am sonntag bis 18 grad und das im
spätwinter ein schöner abend